Frozen popsicles are a delicious way to keep
your kids happy in the hot summer sun, but
the problem is they’re like ticking time-bombs,
just waiting to explode, into sticky, drippy, pools of juice.
So for this video, I’m going to show you
a cool little trick you can do, to make delicious
summertime popsicles, that won’t melt.
All you need for this summer hack, is your
kids favorite box of Jello
Follow the directions on the back of the box,
to make a fruity syrup, the way you normally
would, but rather than setting it to cool
in the fridge, try pouring the juice, into
popsicle molds instead.
With the liquid still hot, go ahead and move
the molds to the freezer, for a couple of
hours, and your cool summertime treats will
be ready in no time.
As easy as that, you’ve just made a colorful
batch of delicious “summer sabers”, that
taste amazing, and are super fun to eat. But
here’s the best part.
When they start warming up and thawing out,
they don’t drip like other popsicles do,
because these ones, are made of Jello.
Jello doesn’t normally drip, and is just
as fun for kids to eat. Which means, you won’t
have the traditional sticky messes to clean
up afterward.
So instead of dealing with sticky faces, sticky
fingers and wasted treats this summer, why
not make a batch of “drip free” popsicles
instead?
Kids love them, they’re super easy to make,
and they’ll save you time and frustration
when it’s time to clean up.
Well that’s it for now. If you liked this
video, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com